[Applaus]
[Musik]
der deutsche michel ist wieder einmal
aus seinem dämmerschlaf erwacht und
stellt sich die vor überraschung
aufgerissen und kulleraugen noch voll
putins sand ganz plötzlich jede frage
die die hier auf ihr soll politik schon
seit jahren thematisieren kann ich kann
europa ohne russisches gas überhaupt
überleben nun die antwort auf diese
frage findet sich in einer nachricht die
fast unbemerkt geblieben ist aber umso
schwerer wiegt nur einen tag für ford
putin in die ukraine einmarschierte fand
das folgende in seiner geostrategischen
bedeutung kaum zu überschätzende treffen
statt die präsidenten russlands und
aserbaidschan treffen sich am dienstag
in moskau
ich weiß viele von euch werden sich
fragen was hat der präsident
aserbaidschans mit dem krieg in der
ukraine oder angst des deutschen vor
kälte in seiner mit billigen disputen
gas geheizt ein stückchen zu tun nun
eine ganze menge im heutigen video
werden wir euch von zwei ländern
erzählen die bisher praktisch unbekannt
waren über die aber in zukunft
wahrscheinlich sehr viel gesprochen
werden wird aber kommt er erst mal
zurück zur ausgangsfrage kann europa
wirklich aufhören erdgas aus russland zu
beziehen gut ich denke dass alles wurde
mittlerweile ausgiebig in allen medien
durch gekauft so dass wir inzwischen
alle wissen dass sich europa und vor
allem deutschland auf fatale weise von
russischem gas abhängig gemacht haben
mehr als 40 prozent des in der gesamten
europäischen union verbrauchten erdgases
kommen aus russland und auch mit oder
ohne krieg in der ukraine alles deutet
darauf hin dass der kreml mit den
europäern weiterhin fed im business
bleiben welt denn sowie design gas
brauchen braucht er geld uns einen
angriffskrieg zu finanzieren als dieses
video gedreht oder hatten russische
truppen ein ukrainisches geburts
krankenhaus bombardiert und bereits
tausende von zivilisten ermordet aber
die gaspipelines lieferten weiterhin gas
in die europäische union und diese
überwies brav ihr geld nach moskau
und ich weiß was er denkt welchen sinn
machen wirtschaftssanktionen gegen
russland wenn ihre haupteinnahmequelle
unangetastet bleibt solange europa der
hauptabnehmer bleibt werden die
milliarden weiterhin die russische
kriegskasse fliesen mit anderen worten
die europäischen politiker können
weiterhin herzzerreißende reden halten
die sätze würdig wären aber das sind
alles billige sprüche wenn wir weiterhin
putins kriege finanzieren schlimmer noch
es ist genau diese heiße luft diese
opportunistische scheinheiligkeit die
uns in genau diese lage gebracht hat und
viele weitere noch schlimmere
situationen bringen wird und was nur
wenige wissen und was selbst jetzt noch
von vielen großen medien verschiedene
wird seit dem ausbruch des krieges in
der ukraine hat die abhängigkeit von
russland sogar noch zugenommen und ich
weiß dass einige von euch jetzt denken
lasst uns dieses oft auf ein fach
bringen wir müssen die hähne für das
blut gas und das blutgeld sofort
abdrehen wenn du dich ziehen wir uns an
der heimatfront die police über schalten
die heizung außen hätten uns mit kalten
duschen ab zeigen wir doch den russen
dass wir nicht jene dekadenten weicheier
denn für die sie uns die ganze zeit
halten die bittere wahrheit ist jedoch
dass der erdgas für viel mehr brauchen
als nur unsere heizung industrie
landwirtschaft und stromerzeugung es ist
klar dass viele einfach nicht bereit
sind den märtyrer zu spielen wir dürfen
nicht einfach so die augen verschließen
und uns einreden dass wir ohne erdgas
einfach unser gewohntes leben
weiterführen könnten das wäre eine
billige und sehr riskante vereinfachung
und ich denke von billigen und riskanten
vereinfachungen haben wir mittlerweile
alle ziemlich die nase voll interessant
ist hierbei auch dass insbesondere all
jene politiker experten und medien die
uns sowieso schon die ganze zeit
veräppelt und in diese misere
hineingeritten haben entschuldigt dass
ich nicht die viel treffen darin kraft
wird das verwende jetzt plötzlich mit
neunmalklugen lösungsvorschlägen kommen
als hätten sie schon immer die weisheit
mit löffeln gegessen darauf kann ich nur
sagen lasst euch nicht ein weiteres mal
von ihnen an der nase herumführen die
frage wir uns heute stellen lautet daher
kann europa wirklich aufhören von
russischem gas abhängig zu sein und gibt
es eine alternative zur derzeitigen
europäischen energiepolitik können wir
dieses problem auf intelligente und
nachhaltige weise lösen ohne dass wir
vom regen in die traufe geraten heute
werden wir all diese fragen beantworten
so schnallt euch an es wird wieder
einmal eine wilde fahrt
[Musik]
der pakt mit dem teufel
ich sage es in aller deutlichkeit ein
teil dessen was jetzt in der ukraine
passiert ist auf die deutsche
energiepolitik zurückzuführen ich weiß
was ich gerade gesagt habe ist
umstritten aber die daten sprechen eine
klare sprache und all die leute die sich
aus der verantwortung stehlen wollen
müssen jetzt farbe bekennen
deutschland genehmigt waffen für die
ukraine ein wichtiger schritt in der
militärhilfe bis samstag war es in
deutschland seit langem üblich die
lieferung tödlicher waffen in
konfliktgebiete zu verhindern es ist
einfach schon zu auffällig geworden
deutschland war einfach in jeder
diskussion über russland immer jenes
land das dem kreml am nächsten stand
fast alle führenden politiker der nie
wieder nation waren nichts anderes als
diktatoren verstehe par excellence und
warum seid ihr euch fragen ganz einfach
am ende eines langen weges der billigen
parolen stand die zynische realpolitik
eine wie sich herausgestellt hat
ziemlich dumme realpolitik dass mich das
erklären deutschland ist der größte
energiekonsument in europa das macht
sinn wenn man bedenkt das ist die größte
volkswirtschaft in der gesamten
europäischen union ist ja und dann kam
aldi belegen slogans man wollte sich ein
wolkenkuckucksheim basteln ganz europa
sollte ein großes bullerbü werden und
zwar egal zu welchem preis die
moralische überhöhung des neuen
deutschen wesens kannte keine grenzen
deutschland will keine kernenergie es
will auch keine kohle es wird auch kein
öl grünen energien haben nur nachteile
und nein eine energiewende im hauruck
verfahren wirkt keinerlei risiken
grundlast was ist das ist das was zu
essen ach ja und strom wir hatten es
gespeichert und so ist durch russischen
kanonendonner geweckt der grüne mich
nicht löslich in der realität aufgewacht
nein es gibt heute keine reale
möglichkeit energie in ausreichenden
ausmaß zu speichern ja es stimmt es gibt
experimentelle technologien zur
energiespeicherung am im moment befinden
sich noch im entwicklungsstadium vom
masseneinsatz weit entfernt was bleibt
ist die traurige realität dass gas
und deshalb wir brauchen sowohl
deutschland als auch europa mehr gas als
je zuvor
im jahr 1990 wurden in deutschland noch
weniger als 40 terawattstunden strom mit
erdgas produziert 2020 waren es bereits
mehr als 94 terawattstunden es stimmt
dass gas relativ gesehen einen
geringeren anteil an mix aus macht aber
in absoluten zahlen kaufen die europäer
immer mehr gas und russland ist der
hauptlieferant betrachtet es doch einmal
so politisch gesehen war für diese
opportunistischen heuchler russisches
gas einfach die gute praktische und
billige energie option gut weil es die
umwelt weniger verschmutzt als kohle
praktisch weil es energie liefert wann
immer wir sie brauchen und billig weil
sie aus russischen pipelines kommt die
bis vor unsere haustür verlaufen und
gute preise bieten und hat denn jemandem
bis auf ein paar visual politik ist es
überhaupt interessiert das all dieser
billige komfort und selbstgefällige
moral narzissmus auf einen pakt mit dem
teufel beruhte ich denke bis jetzt nicht
kein schwein hat ist interessiert
[Musik]
wir haben demonstrationen gegen den
klimawandel und die kernenergie gesehen
aber wer von diesen gestalten die die
ganze zeit in ton angegeben haben und
noch immer angeben wollen hat gegen
putin demonstriert ja lasst uns doch mal
in den kommentaren bilanz ziehen wer
genau vor und nach putins invasion was
gepredigt hat ganz offen und ehrlich
ohne rücksicht auf medien und
parteizugehörigkeit jeder experte
politiker und meinungsmacher der
konstant falsch lag sollte für sein
kolossales versagen zur verantwortung
gezogen werden denn diese leute waren es
welche die zeitenwende wie wir sie jetzt
erleben erst ermöglicht haben und
achtung diese leute versuchen und wieder
die aktuelle notlage zu
instrumentalisieren um uns wieder ihre
eigene agenda zu verkaufen also lasst
uns nicht vergessen was sie uns die
ganze zeit erzählt haben dokumentiert
ist in den kommentaren ross und reiter
müssen benannt werden denn nur wer sich
erinnert kann lernen und nur wer lernt
hat eine zukunft um es ganz offen zu
sagen vor den februar 2022 waren putin
die energieabhängigkeit europas und ein
krieg in der ukraine etwas worüber sich
nur ein paar visual basic zuschauer und
eine handvoll anderer sorgen gemacht
haben niemanden deutschland hat wahlen
verloren weil er oder sie eine enge
beziehung zu putin hatte fast die ganze
nation hat sprichwörtlichen gazprom
trikot für schalke gespielt und dabei
gejubelt und all dies erklärt warum
deutschland anstatt sich nach anderen
gaslieferanten umzusehen nach
möglichkeiten suchte noch mehr und noch
billigeres gas aus russland zu kaufen
und zwar ohne dass es durch die böse
ukraine geleitet werden muss tja und
dann kam der februar 2022 und was
passiert jetzt nun sehen wir uns das
doch mal an
[Musik]
der teufel treibt die schulden ein
all das billige gas aus russland ist nur
auf den ersten blick billig mit jedem
cent den wir sparen entsteht eine
unermessliche schuld gegenüber dem gas
teufel bucht den in einer viel
wichtigeren währung freiheit und wer
sich gegenüber den teufel verschuldet
muss damit rechnen dass dieser die
schuld jederzeit eintreiben wird die
erste konsequenz des krieges mit der
ukraine ist das nordries zwei bis auf
weiteres lahmgelegt wurde dies war keine
leichte entscheidung für deutschland
aber es gab keine andere wahl bis auf
weiteres verkauft russland jedoch
weiterhin gas über die ukraine und über
nostra 1 nach europa die frage laute
daher bis wann und unter welchen
bedingungen achtet bitte darauf was der
stellvertretende vorsitzende des
russischen sicherheitsrates dimitri
medwedew auf twitter von sich gab der
deutsche bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat
angeordnet die zertifizierungsverfahren
für die nord stream pipeline zu stoppen
nun ja willkommen in der schönen neuen
welt in der die europäer schon bald 2000
euro für 1000 kubikmeter erdgas bezahlen
werden metro media der stellvertretender
vorsitzender des russischen
sicherheitsrates es steht nun also außer
frage ob wir weiterhin von russland
überhaupt noch abhängig sein wollen oder
nicht sondern vielmehr wie wir die 40
prozent des gases die wir von russland
beziehen reduzieren können und wie wir
das so schnell wie möglich hin bekommen
zurzeit haben die vereinigten staaten
bereits 60 lng tanker mit verflüssigtem
erdgas entsandt katar hat sich bereit
erklärt uns etwas gas zu verkaufen wenn
russland die lieferungen unterricht also
was jetzt problem löst ganz und gar
nicht denn es ist nur schwer vorstellbar
dass die vereinigten staaten oder katar
das gesamte aus russland stammende gas
ersetzen könnten verflüssigtes erdgas
ist viel teurer als gas das über
pipelines angeliefert wird ok dann
müssen wir uns eben aus der krise sparen
pulli und schal anziehen heizung
aussicht dass warmduscher zum abgewöhnen
und statt des autos das rad nutzen tja
als ich vor ein paar jahren ein gut
wärmegedämmt das haus gebaut habe wusste
ich mir kommt kein gas über die
türschwelle die war daher schon allein
aus ideologischen gründen auf eine
leistungsfähige sole wasser wärmepumpe
welche die heizenergie aus einem
oberflächen er hat collector punkt und
mit strom aus solarzellen auf dem dach
betrieben wird ergänzt durch netz sprung
wenn die sonne mal nicht scheint das
alles funktioniert wunderbar und ist
sogar ein betrieb günstiger als eine
vergleichbare gasheizung aber keine
angst ich werde diesen kanal jetzt nicht
in marcs haustechnik ratgeber umbenennen
auch wenn das ein super spaß das thema
wer denn all dies sind schöne und
nützliche tipps um das eigene gewissen
zu beruhigen mehr aber auch nicht wenn
euch also irgendwelche politiker
experten oder gar als professorin
getarnt adobe ist irgendwas anderes
austauschen wollen wisst ihr woran ihr
seid wie gesagt persönlich wenig wärme
punkten und solarstrom auch ganz toll
aber ich kenne die volkswirtschaftlichen
daten und mache mir und auch euch keine
illusionen eine solarstrom und wärme
punkten offensive könnte nur einen
verschwindend kleinen bruchteil des
erdgasverbrauchs ersetzen in deutschland
gerade einmal 30 von insgesamt 800 30
terawattstunden einsparpotenzial
mit 120 terawattstunden würde sogar eine
sofortige verlängerung der laufzeiten
der atomkraftwerke viermal mehr bringen
und ja da wir nicht von rundfunkgebühren
abhängig sind dürfen wir noch dieses
böse wort in den mund nehmen aber
natürlich werden auch die jetzt
mittelfristig verfügbaren kernkraftwerke
nicht ausreichen und sessel wird die
heizung komplett herunterdrehen würden
wäre das in der jetzigen situation
volkswirtschaftlich vollkommen
irrelevant denn wir können noch so viel
gas beim heizen von gebäuden sparen denn
wir wollen die wirtschaft werden wir
dadurch nicht retten denn durch das
billige gas aus russland hatte die
europäische industrie jahrzehntelang
keinerlei anreize ihre prozesse
energieeffizient zu gestalten
zahlreiche schlüsselbranchen sind zur
richtigen gas junkies geworden wenn
diese nun plötzlich gas zu denselben
preisen die ihre asiatischen
konkurrenten beziehen müssten wäre ihre
wettbewerbsfähigkeit dahin wir stimmten
vor einer gigantischen wirtschaftskrise
danke dass wert und danke mertel die
frage ist also was man jetzt noch tun
kann sollen wir mehr atomreaktoren bauen
das ist langfristig sicher sind voller
stolz ihr ist aber nicht auf die
schnelle weiter es dauert fast zehn
jahre einen kleinen reaktor zu bauen
ganz zu schweigen vom mangelnden
politischen willen ok aber was will dann
die politik aja erneuerbare energien
freiheits energien hat sie sogar
christian lindner genannt auch das
klingt aber toll nicht wahr heißt es
etwa dass wir diese erneuerbaren
energien jetzt plötzlich billig
speichern und transportieren können habe
ich da was hat das talent ja was habe
ich euch über billige slogans und
vereinfachen die heilsversprechen gesagt
wollen wir wirklich entscheidungen
treffen die auf dem versprechen drohen
dass eines tages jemand eine neue
technologie entdecken wird die alles
verändern wird das ganze erinnert doch
sehr an den mythos einer wunderwaffe die
den endsieg bringen wird nein auf diesen
weg sollten wir uns ganz sicher nicht
noch mal begeben also was nun was sind
unsere option wir haben euch doch echte
lösungen versprochen oder ja genau dann
aufgepasst
neue teufel mit denen man praktisch
schließen kann
wir haben es schon zu beginn gesagt die
zeit der billigen und einfachen
heilsversprechen ist vorbei es wird
ungemütlicher und komplexer aber dafür
auch ausgewogene und deswegen
risikoärmer denn schauen wir der
wahrheit ins auge europa hat keine
andere wahl als mit neuen gas teufeln zu
paktieren ja das klingt auf den ersten
blick paradox aber haben wir nicht
gesagt dass wir uns von den billigen
slogans und vereinfachungen abschieden
müssen also es gibt dumme realpolitik
und kluge realpolitik am ende jedoch
siegt immer nur die realpolitik der
trick liegt also darin es diesmal schlau
zu machen und das risiko so zu verteilen
dass man nicht von einem mächtigen
lieferanten abhängig dort man muss die
teufel nach seiner pfeife tanzen lassen
nicht umgekehrt okay aber wie soll das
konkret vonstatten geht nun die
strategie sind einfach so aus all die
teufel gegeneinander auszuspielen indem
man die balance zwischen ihnen allen
behält und sich nie zu abhängig von
einem einzelnen macht denn die
zerstörung genau dieses
marktgleichgewicht zugunsten eines
gasthofes russlands und damit zu
ungunsten europas war die ganze zeit die
hauptaufgabe von putins besten
gasverkäufe gas gerd schröder gut sehen
wir uns mal um der erste alternativ
täusche unserer geschichte ist dieser
herren
[Musik]
darf ich vorstellen ilham aliew der
präsident von aserbaidschan
ich weiß also bei schaden ist eines
jener länder von denen man erst durch
den eurovision songcontest erfahren hat
dass es sie überhaupt gibt okay es gab
damals auch einen recht schlimm krieger
medien wir haben darüber ein video
gedreht
machen wir uns nichts vor wir haben es
mit einer grausamen und korrupt diktatur
zu tun nicht ohne geopolitische probleme
fragt einfach mal die arminia und hier
kommt die nachricht vom anfang dieses
videos ins spiel die präsidenten
russlands und aserbaidschan treffen sich
am dienstag in moskau
dieses treffen von zwei tage vor dem
einmarsch in die ukraine statt sowohl
putin als auch all ihr erklärten sich
die ewige liebe militärische
zusammenarbeit und verständnis aller art
aber für aufmerksame wirst du alle
politik zuschauer sah das nicht ganz
glaubwürdig aus die frage ist nämlich ob
aserbaidschan wirklich der beste
verbündete russlands ist nun die
wahrheit ist ganz bestimmt nicht
zunächst einmal konkurrieren sie mit
moskau toben den verkauf von erdgas aber
nicht nur das der wichtigste
unterstützer aserbaidschans ist die
türkei ein nato-mitglied seit 1952 und
historische feind russlands und
aserbaidschan ist nicht nur für seinen
ausgezeichneten kaviar sondern verfügt
auch über eines der größten erdgasfelder
der welt die berühmten shah deniz felder
mitten im kaspischen meer darüber hinaus
verkauft also bereits 2020 erdgas nach
europa seht euch mal diese karte an
ihr könnt ihr sehen wie das gas vom
kaspischen meer nach süditalien
transportiert wird der bau der pipeline
begann im mai 2016 und wurde im november
2020 abgeschlossen haben also vier jahre
in anspruch damals löste diese pipeline
eine menge kontroversen aus die
propaganda trolle des kremls wurden in
ganz europa aktiv diesmal vor allem in
italien es gelang ihnen sogar die 5
sterne bewegung wie damals angesagteste
politischen partei italiens auf ihre
seite zu ziehen so ein glück haben ist
aber selbst diese köstlichen idioten
putins nicht geschafft das ruder
herumzureißen in der tat haben wir alle
gesehen wie die vogue ort war mit seiner
mannschaft atlético de madrid in der
fußball liga gewandt und dabei das
trikot von aserbaidschan dem land des
feuers trug niemand hat dagegen
protestiert
und jetzt kommt der clou dank dieser
pipeline kann europa heute seine
versorgung weiter diversifizieren
italien und aserbaidschan wollen
gaslieferungen über die trans adriatic
pipeline erhöhen und ihr denkt
wahrscheinlich war es für ein schachzug
wollen wir wirklich einen schrecklichen
diktator durch einen anderen ersetzen
werden wir unsere abhängigkeit von
russland aufgeben um von aserbaidschan
abhängig zu werden nun nein ganz und gar
nicht entspannt euch den erlesenen club
der diktatoren mit natürlichen
ressourcen gibt es einen neuen spieler
jemanden den niemand erwartet hat und
glaubt mir ich bin bis sicher dass
wirklich niemand mit ihm gerechnet hat
[Musik]
der stille teufel
darf ich vorstellen
turkmenistan dieses land ist so
unbekannt dass es noch nicht mal am
eurovision song contest teilnimmt und
das ist ja quasi so als würde das gar
nicht existieren aber spaß beiseite die
zustände in diesem land sind so
schrecklich und bizarr dass sie fast
schon wie eine komödie wirken ich denke
wir sollten ein video darüber drinnen
das wird sicher lustig also aber nicht
vergessen der diktator dieses landes
heißt urban goalie berlin habe dorf bei
seinem unterdrückten volk ist aber eher
bekannt als al qaida quass auf
turkmenische nicht weniger bedeutet als
der beschützer
[Musik]
umwelt pathos nun wie ihr seht ist herr
aka duck der beschützer sozusagen die
comic version von kim jong un um euch
eine vorstellung davon zu geben er ließ
eine 21 meter hohe statue von sich
selbst auf einem pferd reitend errichten
eigentlich ist diese statue aus bronze
aber sie ist mit 24 karätigem gold
überzogen aber was wenn man ein derart
großes ego hat das eine riesige
goldstatue einfach nicht genug ist um es
adäquat präsentieren nun alltag hat sich
eine weitere statue bauen lassen von
seinem hund außerdem komponiert er
beschützer auch seine eigenen rap songs
und gibt konzerte für sein volk das ist
kein scherz keine übertreibung wäre es
nicht so dass er sich um eines der
repressivsten regimes der welt handelt
würde das land wie eine folge von south
park aussehen so kann es und jetzt
haltet mal die luft eine genug gelacht
dort ministern verfügt nämlich über die
vier größten erdgasreserven der welt so
viel wie die der usa und chinas zusammen
genommen das sei der platters und der
einzige große abnehmen des turkmenischen
gases ist derzeit china
seit mehreren jahren versucht das land
aber eine pipeline zu bauen um ist auch
nach indien verkaufen zu können diese
pipeline wird tapie genannt das ist ein
akronym aus den anfangsbuchstaben den
beteiligten länder die minister
afghanistan und pakistan und indien ja
das ist richtig die wirtschaftliche
zurück - tanz hängen lange zeit von
einer gas pipeline ab die ausgerechnet
das schöne afghanistan verlaufen sollte
und wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist
die zukunft dieser part moment ziemlich
ungewiss ich sage nicht dass sie nicht
gebaut werden wird aber wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt ist es im moment sehr
kompliziert überhaupt irgendwas in
afghanistan zu bauen mit anderen worten
herr acker dagmar kann diktator sein
aber er hat erdgas und will es unbedingt
gegen harte devisen verkaufen und das
erklärt nachrichten wie diese abkommen
zwischen aserbaidschan und turkmenistan
ebnet den weg für trans kaspischen
pipeline so sieht's aus bisher hat sich
kaum jemand in europa für turkmenisches
gas interessiert gas gerd hat ganze
arbeit geleistet und die perspektiven
der deutschen energiepolitik zu einem
auf russland gerichteten tunnelblick
reduziert aber jetzt ist der weg vom
fenster und not macht bekanntlich
erfinderisch die lösung liegt auf dem
tisch
es genügt das turkmenische gas an jene
pipeline anzuwenden die aserbaidschan
bereits mit italien und damit
deutschland verbindet europa hält so
direkten zugang zu den viertgrößten
erdgasreserven der welt nichts mit
fracking gas und tankern alles schön
kostengünstig über pipelines darüber
hinaus gibt es im falle pakistans noch
einen weiteren vorteil für europa seht
euch mal diese karte an
seht ihr was ich sehe ja genau dort
wenigsten konkurriert mit russland auf
dem gasmarkt okay aber es hat keine
gemeinsame grenze mit russland das heißt
es ist für den kreml ein schwer ein
zunehmendes land und das ist wie wir
sehen ein großer vorteil denn es gibt
nicht wenige experten der meinung sind
russland hätte sich die creme
hauptsächlich deswegen bei den nagel
gerissen und heftigen keine überfallen
weil im einzugsgebiet der krim riesige
erdgasvorkommen unter dem boden des
schwarzen meers lagern hätte die ukraine
die möglichkeit diese zu erschließen
würde sie die russische erdgas dominanz
über europa brechen und man muss es so
sehen erdgas ist die einzige reale was
für die russland noch gegen europa
geblieben ist sonst hat dieses land
nichts aber auch gar nichts mehr
aufzubringen
es hat auch einen grund nervös zu sein
denn europa hätte in seiner
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft eigentlich
zugang zu gewaltigen erdgasreserven
welche zusammengenommen das russische
gas mehr als ersetzen könnten wenn ja
wenn russische lobbyisten vor allem in
berlin nicht verhindert hätten dass die
eu frühzeitig in eine diversifizierte
unabhängige gas infrastruktur investiert
viele länder mit großen reserven hatten
aufgrund der russischen marktdominanz
und des desinteresses der europäer
überhaupt keine anreize förderanlagen
und pipelines zu bauen und während
europa nun hastig und verzweifelt nach
alternativen zu russischem erdgas bucht
hat das eigentlich schon lange mehrere
davon direkt unter der nase zb im
mittelmeer südlich von super vor israels
küste diese vorkommen sind den
sibirischen qualitativ mindestens
ebenbürtig wobei sibirien sogar noch
weiter entfernt ist als das mittelmeer
und israel verfügt nicht nur über
genügend erdgas für den eigengebrauch
sondern beliefert schon lange
nachbarländer wie jordanien und ägypten
nach europa gibt es bisher jedoch keine
pipeline und damit sich das
entsprechende projekt namens easter egg
lohnen würde müsste sicher sei dass
europa das erdgas mindestens über zehn
oder 15 jahren abnimmt der rentabilität
von ismet stand jedoch immer die
konkurrenz durch nord stream 1 und 2 im
weg die eu hat die ismet pipeline zwar
formal unterstützt aber es fanden sich
keine unternehmen in europa die sich
verpflichtet hätten dieses gas
langfristig abzunehmen da hat er das
geld über seinen berliner netzwerk
geschickt die fäden zog um all die zu
verhindern aus diesem grund war auch
keine bank bereit den bau der pipeline
zu finanzieren ein weiteres problem
hauptcharakter israelis mit sind typen
und griechenland daher ist das projekt
dem türkischen präsidenten erdogan ein
gewaltiger dorn im auge erinnert ihr
euch noch wir haben ein ganzes video
über den türkisch griechischen gaskrieg
gedreht und ich werde es euch natürlich
verlinken aus rücksicht auf die nato
partner türkei hat daher auch die
us-regierung unter beiden ist mit bisher
steine in den weg gelegt gab jetzt
jedoch angesichts der russischen
aggression grünes nicht der geopolitik
ist manchmal eben ein ziemlicher break
irgendwie treibt es abwechselnd jeder
mit jedem gegen jeden gut bleibt noch
die frage zu klären ob es wirklich auf
die schnelle das heißt bis zum nächsten
wintereinbruch in europa möglich ist in
wird minister genügend förderkapazität
auszubauen nun wir müssen
berücksichtigen dass es sich um eines
der am stärksten unter entwickelten
länder der welt handelt um eine diktatur
in der die rechtssicherheit eher ein
fremdwort ist in diesem fall könnte dies
ein nachteil sein aber auch ein vorteil
in unserem vorigen video über den
untergang das mit und haben geräuchert
erzählt dass gerade planwirtschaftliche
und zentralistische strukturen in der
lage sind im hauruck-verfahren riesige
projekte zu stemmen das bedeutet wenn
der politische wille da ist und das
notwendige kapital aus europa bereit
gestellt wird ist alles möglich an
dieser stelle sei daran erinnert dass
saudi arabien vor 100 jahren nicht viel
besser dran war als hotrod minister das
gleiche gilt natürlich für die
aufstockung der pipelines die bisherige
kapazität der trasse adria pipeline von
zehn milliarden kubikmetern soll noch
dieses jahr durch neue leistungsfähigere
pumpen auf 25 milliarden steigen und
sich durch ein weiteres parallel rohr im
nächsten jahr auf sage und schreibe 60
milliarden mehr als verdoppeln falls das
geld jedoch schneller in die hand
genommen würde könnten die 60 milliarden
schon im nächsten winter bereitstehen
und nächstes jahr dann vielleicht schon
120 milliarden womit bereits die hälfte
des russischen gasimporte ersetzt wäre
und das beste an der geschichte all das
bedeutet natürlich nicht dass europa gar
kein gas mehr aus russland beziehen muss
klar aus moralischen gründen sollte es
das nicht mehr tun wenn es jedoch durch
minister dabei hilft zu einem
ernstzunehmenden gründen aufzusteigen
wird dies erhebliche
verhandlungsspielräume vor europa
schaffen und den preis für das russische
blut gastiert an die republik scan zu
drücken dass putin und mit ihr das gar
nicht mehr aus dem rollen herauskommen
[Musik]
dann haben europa und auch deutschland
dieses große geopolitische schachspiel
für sich entschieden putin muss weiter
gas liefern erzielt aber kaum noch
gewinne mit denen er seine kriegerischen
ambitionen finanzieren kann europa
können weiterhin kostengünstig gas
nutzen und wettbewerbsfähig bleiben und
auch die usa und katar müssen talente
etwas günstiger anbieten plötzlich würde
sich das blatt gewaltigen wenden es ist
gut dass nun viel mehr politiker
begreifen dass eine einseitige auf kante
genähte energiepolitik hochgradig
riskant ist der polnische
premierminister morath jetzt geht zum
beispiel sagte polen könne in zwei bis
drei jahren vollkommen unabhängig von
russischem gas werden hierzu wird die
polnische regierung unter anderem sofort
640 millionen euro für die
rekapitalisierung von gaz system den
betreiber des erdgasnetzes in polen
bereitstellen morawski betonte es gebe
keinen preis der für unsere
wertegemeinschaft so hoch sei um weiter
von russischen rohstoffen abhängig zu
bleiben europa stünde vor
wirtschaftlichen turbulenzen
er hatte jedoch gestärkt aus ihnen
hervorgehen wenn es nur mutig und
entschlossen handeln tja nur die harten
kommen in den garten redundanz
diversifikation und endlich wieder mehr
wettbewerb sind die schlüssel zur
langfristig nachhaltigen stabilen
energieversorgung europas aber vorsicht
das sprechen hier immer noch
hauptsächlich von risikominimierung es
bedeutet nicht dass die gewinnung neuer
lieferanten alle energieprobleme lösen
wird langfristig wird es weiterhin
wichtig seien weitgehende energie
unabhängigkeit zu erreichen ja die
erneuerbaren freiheits energien sind
eine langfristige vision aber dieses und
nächstes und übernächstes jahr helfen
sie uns kein bisschen weiter fällt also
bitte nicht mehr auf jene politiker
herein die mit billigen heilsversprechen
jenen kontrollverlust übertünchen wollen
indem sie euch selbst hinein geführt
haben sie brauchen wieder einen klugen
energiemix und ausreichend backup
kapazitäten erneuerbare energien sind
die zukunft aber planvoll und nachhaltig
eingeführt nicht im durch
straßenblockaden angeheizten panik modus
und nicht indem man sich von schwierigen
typen wie gas gehört um den finger
wickeln lässt diese lobbyisten haben das
politische berlin und die deutsche
öffentlichkeit dazu gebracht auf putin
den garanten der energiewende zu machen
ohne sich dies einzugestehen diese
hochgradig gefährliche lebenslügen muss
nun sofort aufgeklärt und korrigiert
werden denn mit den richtigen
politischen willen ist es sogar jetzt
möglich sich aus der abhängigkeit von
russland zu lösen europa ist noch zu
retten die springende frage lautet also
wird ist dieses mal wirklich diesen
richtigen politischen willen geben
werden wir wirklich erleben dass europa
eine klare konsequente und ausgewogenen
energiepolitik an den tag legt was meint
ihr und was noch wichtiger ist werden
die spieler von schalke und barcelona
darf für das antlitz von aka den
beschützer turkmenistans und jetzt auch
europas auf ihren trikots tragen müssen
wir immer so wir eure meinung und
kommentare schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat und
ja vielleicht auch das land hat
allerdings kein leid taten folgen das
heißt nicht dass aber mit glück keines
unseren videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen uns auch hier das zeit
über die spende von euch mit der kunst
hält dieses projekt weiterzuführen den
paypal ihn dazu mit der beschreibung
unter diesem video macht es gut und bis
bald
[Musik]